many people know the sound of vinyl but
it's how it's made that's a whole
different story
the record industry offers a one-stop
shop for all our customers
so we do the cuts in-house on both lack
of dmm we produce our own coppers
we do the print of all the sleeves
labels
so the customer doesn't have to go to
other printers or cutting rooms to get
all this stuff together we do everything
in-house
[Music]
this is ton the proud owner of record
industry one of the largest vinyl
pressing plants in the world
located in harlem in the netherlands tom
has had a lifelong love of vinyl
i started this my music career as being
a dj
in a local club pirate radio stations
playing the old disco dance groups in
the 80s the factory opened in 1958 in
recent years has seen a surge in sales
last year we did nine and a half million
and this year we're aiming for
10 million 500 maybe 11 million
we pressed for all the major companies
being sony music universal warning music
and a lot of local smaller labels my
wife and me try to run record industry
as being a family company we don't have
children ourselves but at the end we're
always making a bit fun of it and we say
we have 100 children here
[Music]
i like the vinyl i like the size of the
format
nice pictures you know
you can say you can be proud on this
product uh and if you look at a cd for
instance it's not something you you're
cherishing a record you cherish
the music was more some kind of a hobby
so i could turn my hobby into a real
profession running this beautiful plant
[Music]
you